good morning everyone
sorry
keep you waiting a little bit i uh
had the honor of spending some time with
the ukrainian prime minister who's in
town
today and uh he is meeting with some of
my cabinet members including the
secretary of treasury and others
and uh
we had a good discussion i've talked
about what i'm about to tell you about
today
as well as uh he was
thanking the american people for their
support understands it's significant and
uh
was we talked about keeping everyone
together in terms of europe the european
union and others
in the effort to uh stop putin's uh
brutality
uh but uh before i head out to the west
coast i wanna quickly uh
update the american people on the latest
steps we're taking to support the people
of ukraine and the hold putin
accountable for its brutal and bloody
war
russian forces have retreated from keith
leaving behind them a horrifying
evidence and you've seen it you reported
it your folks and by the way i i i don't
say this often but i think we should
give enormous credit to the folks with
your agencies that are on the ground in
ukraine in these spots and uh they're
they're really
i've spoken to several of them it's uh
we owe them
but uncovering these evidences of their
atrocities and war crimes against
ukrainian people is so clear to the
whole world now
now they've launched and refocused their
campaign to seize new territory in
eastern ukraine
and we're in a critical window now a
time where
that they're going to set the stage for
the next phase of this war and the
united states and our allies and
partners are moving as fast as possible
to continue to provide ukraine the
forces that they need the weapons they
need excuse me the equipment they need
their forces need to defend their nation
last week i signed an 800 million dollar
package of security assistance to
ukraine that included new capabilities
like artillery systems and armored
personnel carriers equipment that is
responsive to ukraine's needs and
tailored to support the intensified
fighting in the donbass region which is
a different war than in other places
because both topographically it's
different it's flat it's it's not in the
mountains and it requires different
kinds of weapons to be
more effective today i'm announcing
another 800 million dollars to further
augment ukraine's ability to fight in
the east in the donbass region
this package includes heavy artillery
weapons
dozens of howitzers and 144 thousand
rounds of ammunition to go with those
howitzers it also includes more tactical
drones
in the past two months we've moved
weapons and equipment to ukraine at
record speed we've sent thousands of
anti-armor and anti-missile helicopters
drones grenade launchers machine guns
rifles radar systems
more than 50 million rounds of
ammunition at arduino center the united
states alone has provided 10 anti-armor
systems for every one russian tank
that's in ukraine a 10-1 ratio
we're sharing and will continue to share
significant timely intelligence with
ukraine to help defend them against
russian aggression
and on top of this these direct
contributions from the united states
we're facilitating we're the outfit
facilitating the significant flow of
weapons and systems to ukraine from
other allies and partners
around the world
like the s 300 long-range anti-aircraft
systems that slovakia recently
transferred to the crane we are getting
them in there
we won't always be able to advertise
everything we that our partners are
doing to support ukraine and fight for
freedom but to modernize teddy
roosevelt's famous advice sometimes we
will speak softly and carry a large
javelin because we're sending a lot of
those in as well
you know but we're not we're not sitting
on the funding that congress has
provided for ukraine we're sending it
directly to the front lines of freedom
to the fearless and skilled ukrainian
fighters who are standing in the breach
you gotta admit you have must be amazed
at the courage of this country the
resolve that they're showing
not just the military military but the
average citizen
men and women young young men young
women as well
it's you know the sustained and
coordinated support of the international
community
led and facilitated by the united states
has is a significant reason why ukraine
is able to stop russia from taking over
their country thus far
every american taxpayer
every member of our armed forces can be
proud of the fact that our country's
generosity and the skill and service of
our military helped arm and repel
russia's aggression in ukraine
to beat back putin's savagery that tried
to seize ukraine's capital and wipe out
ukraine's government the battle of kyiv
was a historic victory for the
ukrainians
it was a victory for freedom
won by the ukrainian people with
unprecedented assistance by the united
states and our allies and our partners
now
now we have to accelerate that
assistance package to help prepare
ukraine for russia's offensive that's
going to be more limited in terms of
geography but not in terms of brutality
not in terms of brutality
combined with our recent drawdowns it
will ensure a steady flow of weapons and
equipment into ukraine over the next few
weeks however
with this latest disbursement
i'm almost exhausted the drawdown
authority i have that congress
authorized for ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month
in order to sustain
ukraine for the duration of this fight
next week i'm going to have to be
sending to congress a supplemental
budget request to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue to deliver economic assistance
to the ukrainian people
hope
my hope is my expectation is congress
would move and act quickly
i want to thank the congress democrats
and republicans for their support for
the people of ukraine
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and our unity with the ukrainian people
is sending an unmistakable message to
putin
he will never succeed in dominating and
occupying all of ukraine he will not
that will not happen
in addition to bolstering ukraine's
resistance on the battlefield we're also
demonstrating our support for the people
of ukraine today the united states is
announcing that we've intend to provide
an additional 500 million dollars in
direct economic assistance to the
ukrainian government
this brings our total economic support
for ukraine to one billion dollars in
the past two months
this is money the government can help
use to stabilize their economy
to support communities that have been
devastated by the russian onslaught
and pay the brave workers that continue
to provide essential services to the
people of ukraine
you know these past weeks have seen a
terrible human cost of putin's ambition
for conquest and control
approximately two-thirds two-thirds of
all ukrainian children have been
displaced in their home
more than 5 million ukrainians have fled
their country
it's an absolute outrage
the idea this is happening
approaching the second quarter of the
21st century is just
last month when i was in europe i
announced the united states would
welcome 100 000 ukrainians
so that we share in the responsibility
of supporting ukrainians fleeing putin's
war machine
we've already welcomed tens of thousands
of ukrainians to the united states and
today
i'm announcing a program unite for
ukraine a new program to enable
ukrainians seeking refuge to come
directly from europe to the united
states this new humanitarian parole
program
will complement the existing legal
pathways available to ukrainians
including
immigrant visas and refugees processing
it will provide an expedient channel for
secure legal migration from europe to
the united states for ukrainians who
have a u.s sponsor such as a family or
an ngo
this program will be fast it will be
streamlined and will ensure the united
states honors its commitment to go to
the to the people of ukraine and need
not go through our southern border
we're also continuing to ratchet up the
pressure on putin and further isolate
russia on the world stage
yesterday the treasury department rolled
out additional measures to crack down on
the entities and individuals attempting
to evade our unprecedented sanctions not
just ours but throughout the west
today i'm announcing that the united
states will ban
russian-affiliated ships from our ports
as they did in europe that means no ship
no ship that sails under the russian
flag or that is owned or operated by a
russian interest will be allowed to dock
in the united states port or access our
shores none
none
this is yet another critical step we're
taking in concert with our partners in
european union united kingdom canada and
further to deny
russia the benefits of international
economic system that they so enjoyed in
the past
we don't know how long this war will
last
but as we approach the two-month mark
here's what we do know
putin has failed to achieve his grand
ambitions on the battlefield
after weeks of shelling
still stands
president zielinski and his democratic
elected government still remain in power
and the ukrainian armed forces joined by
many brave ukrainian civilians have
thwarted russia's conquest of their
country
they've been bolstered from day one by
an unstinting supply of weapons
ammunition armor intelligence from the
nations of the free world led by us the
united states
as russia continues to grind out the
military advances
and their military advances in the
brutalities against ukraine
putin is banking on us losing interest
that's been my view you heard me say
this from the beginning he was counting
on nato european union our allies in in
asia cracking moving away
he's betting on western unity will crack
he's still betting on that
and once again we're going to prove him
wrong
we will not lessen our evolve
we're going to continue to stand with
the brave and proud people of ukraine
we will never fail in our determination
to defend freedom and oppose tyranny
it's as simple as that
so again i want to thank the american
people
thank the american people for their
support
of the ukrainian people
this is our this is our responsibility
it seems to me and we've been able to
hold the whole world together in this
effort so thank you very much thank you
mr president
i'm going to take this one one or two
questions
what does putin claiming control over
mariopol mean is that how significant is
that
well first of all it's questionable
whether he does control mario paul one
thing for sure we know about mario paul
he should allow humanitarian carters to
let people on that steel mill and other
places are buried under rubble to get
out to get out that's what any any
any head of state would do in such a
circumstance and so uh there is no
evidence yet that mary paul is
completely full
lifting title 42 no what i'm considering
is continuing to hear from my
uh my
first of all there's going to be an
appeal
by the justice department
because as a matter of principle we want
to be able to be in a position where if
in fact it is
strongly concluded by
the
scientists that we need title 42 that
we'd be able to do that but there has
been no decision on extending title 42.
thank you
how long can the u.s maintain the level
and pace of this military support for
ukraine
i well we have the capacity to do this
for
a long time
the question is
are we going to continue to
maintain the support of the
international community
and keep the pressure
on putin to prevent him from overrunning
the country number one and number two
make sure we continue to maintain the
economic sanctions which over time
and we're beginning to see it are
devastating their economy and their
ability to move forward so the most
important thing right now
is maintain the unity so far so good
thank you very much
thank you